hi there good evening everybody can I
just start off by saying how amazing it
is to share a room with some of the most
inspirational women in the world
schoolroom second now then Glamour Man
of the Year award I didn't know this is
what I got now I just want to start by
saying this person who's winning this
tonight definitely deserves it
he's a very close and fierce friend of
mine and has been throughout my whole
career actually been there through every
step and stage of my career so far and I
found out recently that he actually
really wants to be in a boy band so now
I can probably class a lot of his
actions as just pure stalking now
although he never quite made it as the
Signum one direction he's gone on to do
amazing things he's won a Tony Award two
Emmys he's a BAFTA award-winning writer
and he's also got the biggest TV show in
America right now he's taken the country
by storm and he's a global YouTube
sensation for his carpool karaoke which
we all know and love and every superstar
wants to be on hint-hint now most of you
won't know about James he was actually
in a boy band when he was younger he
created one at school he was 16 years
old and he auditioned everybody himself
purely just to make sure that he could
be the lead singer and I've actually got
some of the lyrics a from the pan I'm
gonna read in a moment the band was
called insatiable it she's a word I've
never said before up until now I'm not
reassured it means but we're going to
find out insatiable the slogan was we
never had a slogan I'm feeling like if
we had a slogan Zayn Maya stayed never
mind
I know for next time the slogan was
because you can't get enough and I know
that that is definitely true with this
man because that's the way I feel about
him now the lyrics that he wrote for
insatiable he wrote these himself and
now he's 16 so just cut him a break here
I've wrote some pretty poor ones myself
and my time girl are you ready just tell
me when you're ready girl are you ready
I ain't gonna rush it
girl are you ready we're just going
steady girl are you ready I ain't gonna
rush yet now to me James it sounds like
you were rushing just a little bit
Glamour's man of the year a tonight
six-member one direction the insatiable
mr. james corden give it up thanks very
much for this yeah sorry about those
lyrics it's a little em it's a little
much it was never for me being in the
boy band
however this said this night here just
thinking about it tonight it had a huge
impact on my life this whole evening I
used there was a few years ago where I
err I hosted this award show and it was
not as well as Jennifer I should say
whoo let's be honest has been amazing
tonight let's give her a round of
applause truly [ __ ] dawn French I mean
come on but I was thinking today I was
thinking about coming here and I was
thinking that I when I hosted this thing
was the first thing I'd ever hosted in
my life and I remember thinking
afterwards Oh rather enjoyed that and
now that is a part of my life and I'm
very very honored to be back here I've
stood on this stage here and watched any
number of very very chiseled handsome
men win this award and I feel I'm really
doing it for the big fellas to show that
anything is possible but thank you Joe
thank you glamour you've always been an
incredible supporter of mine you were
the first magazine to ever give me an
interview you were the first magazine I
ever wrote something for and you're the
you're the first magazine to name me a
singular man of the year and it would be
remiss of me if I was his or not thank
just a few people and I really thought
that tonight I should probably just
thank I've been very lucky that my whole
life and career has been shaped by some
amazing women ruth young who is my agent
jodie Gottlieb who is in America Ruth
Jones who I wrote Gavin & Stacey with
who is
it's good a woman as you'll ever meet
Christine Gernon who directed every
single minute and second of Gavin &
Stacey and is is amazing and my wife
that our daughter who we have created
together who those two are my favorite
women in the world and also my mum and
my sisters and I brought my big sister
with me tonight though she's very very
cross because I didn't actually tell her
that she was coming with me so she's
very underdressed so cut her some slack
like don't just hand her your drink or
something or go over and tell her
there's been a spillage bye table 13
she's she's at and we've got to leave in
a minute because she's lost her phone
it's in a Sainsbury's in there we did
the Apple thing she's found it so we got
to leave in a minute but thank you very
very much it's - it's genuinely true
thank you very very much and thank you
to Murray for the truth he's wearing
that t-shirt on that magazine it didn't
even occur to me that that would ever be
anything that should even be considered
as brave because I don't think it should
be and I long for the day when it isn't
a time where we would talk about women's
rights when we would talk about equality
in any of those things that it would
just be a matter of facts of the world
that we are living in nights like
tonight I truly believe take everyone a
step closer than that this means a lot
to me thanks Joe thank you all very very
much
[Applause]